It is so great to see you again.
-Gosh, it's so great to --
I'm sorry about that
whole sitting fiasco.
It's been a while since I was
on a talk show.
-"No, you hang up."
"No, you hang up."
Yeah, exactly.
-"You hang up."
-I want to talk to you about
"Joe vs. Carole."
Great job, by the way.
-Wow. Thanks.
-And I really do --
I want to talk about that
and how you got into it.
-And we will, you know.
-And we will.
But, first,
"Saturday Night Live."
-Yeah.
-You just crush it.
I love seeing you on there,
and I go,
"How many years has
Kate been on?"
I go, "Five years?"
You've been on
for almost 10 years.
-It's been 10 years, which is --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It doesn't feel like -- Does it
feel like 10 years to you?
-It feels like a day.
It feels like
ten-hundred-thousand
billion years.
I don't remember the beforetime.
I only remember
the last 10 years,
and, like, it's changed
my concept of time.
Like, I no longer think of
Tuesday as, like, Tuesday.
I think of it as, like,
writing night.
-Writing night. Yeah.
-And...
-Me too.
-Yeah. Still?
-Yeah.
-Oh, boy.
-Tuesdays, yeah,
I teach my kids.
It does stick in your head.
-It's a good system.
-Yeah. That's "SNL" stuff, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Well, congrats on 10 years.
I can't believe
it's been almost 10 years.
You're fantastic.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thanks.
-Oh, you know,
I also want to bring up
you're going to be in
the new "Barbie" movie.
-"Barbie" movie!
-No, you are,
with Margot Robbie.
This is --
-I know!
-Greta Gerwig.
-Can you even believe?
-Directing!
Yes. Ryan Gosling -- Ken!
-Yes, I know!
-Ken and Barbie!
-This is a big -- Aah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Greta Gerwig. "Barbie" movie.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe my good fortune.
-No, seriously.
What is -- Do you know Greta
at all, Greta Gerwig?
-I went to college with
Greta, yeah.
We lived in the same
disgusting dorm suite.
I mean, a dorm suite so filthy,
a dorm suite
with vomit in the tub
that you -- You don't know
where it came from.
-Just something got sick
in your tub.
-And you don't know
who's going to clean it up,
and no one does.
And that's -- So, that's how
I know Greta, yeah.
-Wow! And you told me
that you loved the script.
-I loved -- Oh, it's one of the
greatest things I've ever read.
It's going to be --
[ Clicks tongue ]
Just you wait.
-Yeah, just you wait.
'Enry 'Iggins, just you wait.
-You -- "Just you wait."
You filmed your new series,
"Joe vs. Carole," in Australia.
-"Joe vs. Carole."
-Yes, on Peacock, yeah.
I just want to talk about
Australia for a second,
because, gosh, I always
wanted to go to Australia.
Not only do I love Australia,
but I love Australians.
-You've got to go.
You've got to go.
You go for the people.
You go for the animals.
-There are a lot of
scary animals.
-A lot of scary animals.
A lot of anodyne animals,
beautiful little animals,
who don't kill you.
And I sort of stuck
with those ones.
-Yeah, not the spiders
and the sharks and stuff.
-There was my first day there.
I was walking on the street and
I saw what I thought was
the most beautiful bird
I've ever seen in my life.
Like, this gigantic thing
with a beautiful white plumage
and a long, elegant beak
and, like,
flapping and just walking
on the sidewalk.
And I was like,
"What is this majestic heron
just loose in the street
that I've encoun--
Oh, my God,
I've been blessed here.
This is a sight!"
And I asked some guy that
I ran into -- I was like,
"What is this gorgeous bird?"
And he was like,
"Oh, that's a bin chicken."
And what I learned was that
the ibis is called a bin chicken
because they eat garbage
out of the dumpsters.
And that is their pigeons,
and they have about eight songs
about how much they hate them.
And, to me, this was, like,
the most beautiful thing
I've ever seen.
-To them, it's a pigeon.
-And they were like,
"Oh, the ibis.
We hate the ibis."
-What other animals did you see
when you were in Australia?
-I saw -- I mean, not to brag,
I saw a kangaroo.
-Yo!
-Okay?
-Are they in the wild?
No, kangaroos.
-There's loose wallabies.
-Really?
-Just loose.
-On the set, just loose.
And I'm like --
I see these wallabies
and I'm like, "A wallaby!"
And they were like,
"Yeah, they're there."
-"They're there."
-"That's a wallaby."
-"So what?"
-Did you pick up slang?
Australian -- did you pick up
the accent?
-I picked --
There's a lot of great slang.
Everything is abbreviated.
So, sunglasses become sunnies.
Mosquitoes become mozzies.
But the best thing I heard was,
the gal who was
doing my makeup --
Hi, Cath, hi, Iris, hi, Brie.
Mwah! She said
she needed to scoot
the wig down just a little bit.
So she said, "Okay, we're just
going to move it a bee's dick."
And I was like, "Say again?"
[ Rimshot ]
Thank you.
-That's actually very good.
-Which is just the smallest
length of distance
that you could imagine.
-I've never heard that.
-Just the smallest little bit.
And come to learn,
that's not an Australian thing.
That's just her.
-Oh, okay. Oh, interesting.
Wow. It's good to know
that, yeah.
-She's just that good.
-Well, the series is
based on the podcast.
You were working this
before I saw "Tiger King."
-Yes. This amazing podcast
came out,
and I listened to it
and I was like,
"Oh, my gosh, this
Carole Baskin -- what a kook."
I love kooks.
I love kooky ladies.
I'm always on the hunt.
-Yeah.
-And then
the documentary came out,
and I felt like
she didn't really --
People didn't
walk away with, like,
the most rounded picture of
who she is, what she's about,
and what she's been through.
She's had quite a tough life.
And, you know, her main thing --
her main thing -- is, like,
trying to end
private ownership of big cats
in the United States.
Because I don't know if
you guys know this.
There are currently more tigers
living in cages in captivity
in the United States
than there are
in the wild in the whole world.
-Is that right?
-And it's just like,
you know, we revere these.
These are majestic animals.
You wouldn't do that
to something you revere.
You wouldn't put Olivia Rodrigo
in, you know,
a cage in your backyard.
So it just makes no sense.
-She's a national treasure.
We would never do that to
Olivia Rodrigo.
-She's a national treasure.
-Of course.
That's a great example.
Thank you.
That's a great --
-I know. That's what I'm saying.
So, you know, it's equivalent.
And, so,
that's her life's mission.
And I thought, "Well, you know,
she deserves some
reconsideration."
-That's interesting.
-You know?
-Did you get to know her at all?
Did you meet her?
-I haven't met her, but she's
done this amazing project
of putting her entire life story
on YouTube every day
for the last two years.
And I watched that and I feel
like I know her and --
-Yeah, exactly, yeah.
-And I got more of
a sense of what she's about.
She's an introvert
and a workaholic and --
-Okay. Yeah, hello.
I like that you've found
this new take on her.
I think it's really cool
that you did that.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Kate McKinnon in
"Joe vs. Carole."
Take a look.
-What they're counting on is
you getting tired of fighting.
Yeah.
Tiger in the wild can't take
a day off, though, right?
-No.
-Tiger in the wild can't go to
the pool and read a book.
Tiger in the wild's
got to be...
[ Clicks tongue ]
...laser-focused.
His whole life is a fight.
So I don't know.
You want to take a day off
or you want to be a tiger?
-Be a tiger.
-Tiger.
-Yeah.
-I thought so.
-Yeah! Let's be a tiger.
Kate McKinnon, everybody!
"Joe vs. Carole" premieres this
Thursday on Peacock.